so not speaker this morning ever Moscow
for Microsoft was talking about matrix
approximation yes I'm going to be
talking about basically some recent
advances in approximating specifically
positive semi-definite matrices and just
some work we've been trying to do an
understanding what sort of structure can
we exploit a positive semi-definite
matrices to get low-rank approximation
as much faster than we can get for just
general matrices so every here probably
knows on a PSD matrix is it's basically
just a symmetric matrix a that is all
non-negative eigenvalues another way to
look at this is it's just a matrix that
if I take the dot product of a vector x
over it this is always non-negative so X
transpose ax is always non-negative and
these sorts of matrices show up all the
time in applications they include things
like graph laplacian z-- grande matrices
kernel matrices which are sort of
nonlinear grande matrices covariance
matrices has scenes of convex functions
they just appear in all sorts of
applications so understanding basically
how to operate on PSD matrices is a sort
of fundamental thing in the near algebra
another thing about PSD matrices is that
often we get really big ones and we get
ones that are really big and really
dense so often we like generate really
large PSD matrices from much smaller
data sets so an example of this is in
kernel methods things like kernel Ridge
regression which is very closely related
to sort of equivalent to Gaussian
process regression where it's called
kriging and the geosciences kernel
distance measures like maximum
discrepancy which are sort of ways of
testing distances between distribution
using kernels in all these methods what
I do is I start with some data some set
of data points with D features I have n
data points with D features and I want
to sort of work with these data points
in a non linear space so what I do is I
sort of mapped this original data set to
a kernel matrix what this is is
basically the I J at the entry of this
kernel matrix is equal to the dot
product between data point I and data
point J but this dot product is on some
under some nonlinear inner product so
like the Gaussian kernel or so maybe
when you sing
so basically every entry of K is
determined by these nonlinear distances
between the rows in X once I have done
this transformation a lot of these
problems like Colonel Ridge regression
Gaussian process regression reduced to
basic linear algebraic computations on K
the problem is that K can be really huge
so if I even want to write down K or for
example perform a single iteration of a
linear system solved if I just want to
multiply by a vector I'm suddenly paying
roughly N squared time where n was my
original number of data points so if I
have large data sets if I have even like
a mildly sized data set say of a hundred
thousand data points suddenly K has ten
billion entries suddenly it's a matrix
that takes a ton of space to store it's
a big linear algebraic problem and
typically these things are gonna be
dense so typically K this kernel
function is gonna map to nonzero numbers
so typically it's gonna be a really
large dense matrix so I need to
basically do something about this if I
want to sort of apply these kernel
methods to reasonably sized datasets so
there's sort of two options one is I
could just apply paralyzation massive
computation I could sort of form K in
parallel I could multiply a by n in
parallel I could do everything in a
distributed way so this is one approach
we could take the approach that I'm
gonna be looking at today is basically
how can we develop effective
approximations for these large PSD
matrices so instead of working with K I
can work with sort of a much more
compressed representation of them and
specifically I'm gonna be talking about
a specific type of compressed
representation that a lot of people here
are gonna be talking about which is
low-rank approximation basically like as
Ming was showing for you often see
spectral K and matrices and you can
exploit this by basically approximating
a matrix by a low rank matrix and
showing that it's close to it so what I
want to look at is if I have a PSD
matrix a how can I really efficiently
compute a low-rank approximation and
then transpose that's as close to as
good as I could get for a and do this
without paying this whole N squared
runtime cough
so traditional low-rank approximation
methods things like say computing a full
SVD or doing curl op subspace methods
regular link you are random projection
all of these methods at least require
usually more but at least require
multiplying one vector by your matrix so
the case about dense and by n matrix
they at least require n squared time and
when n is large we want to totally avoid
this so there's a lot of methods that
have been proposed that require less
time that basically require little o of
N squared so this is like think of as
being sub linear time you're gonna try
to get an approximation without reading
your full matrix K things like
incomplete cholesky entry wise sampling
nice Strom approximation this random for
a features method which is used a lot in
machine learning can be viewed as
basically a randomized low-rank
approximation method so lots of these
methods exist I'll just point out that
this has been a really successful near
algebraic method so like nice Trauma
approximation random for your features
are essentially randomized low-rank
approximation x' and they're sort of
what's used in practice to approximate
these large kernel matrices they're sort
of what we have these different bound
these different methods they have
various bounds lots of different bounds
exists some are stronger some are weaker
some uses assumption somes don't use
assumptions there's nothing as strong as
what we typically see for like our fast
algorithms for general matrices so
generally sort of like in this community
one thing that we often try to get is
lowering approximation of the form a the
distance between a and n n transpose say
in the Frobenius norm is within 1 plus
epsilon of the best low-rank
approximation this is between a and a K
is a K is the projection of a onto its
top K eigenvectors so I want to get
these sorts of bounds for PSD matrices
but I want to do it without paying n
squared run time I want to basically do
it a little low n square outside so
that's the goal we want strong
worst-case approximation bounce no
assumptions on the matrix but sublinear
time methods to get these sorts of
results
another way of looking at this is in
many contexts as I explained what we're
doing is we're taking a moderately sized
data set we're blowing it up to this big
PSD matrix this kernel matrix and then
what we want is some sort of compressed
representation and this is inherently an
expensive pipeline what I want to do is
sort of cut out this middle step I want
to say I take an initial input matrix I
skip like forming this full PSD matrix
this kernel matrix or wherever it's
coming from and I go right to a
compressed low-rank approximation that's
close to this matrix thing so first of
all let me talk about why we can't hope
to do this without this positive
semi-definite structure so I'm telling
you I want to get a good alluring
approximation to a and I don't want to
read all of its entries I want to run a
little over N squared time even when a
is dense this is clearly an impossible
goal if a is a general matrix so for any
general matrix if I want any sort of
approximation bound to it I better read
the holding so specifically if I just
place a random really large entry in the
matrix a they say the matrix is all
really small entries and I just take one
that I'll make matrix and make it really
large basically any good approximation
to a is gonna have to know that that
entry is large and so if I even want to
identify that in truth conscience Scott
constant probability it's in a random
location I can't really do anything
about randomly guess where it is I
basically need to read a constant
fraction of the nonzero entries and a in
order to find this large entry so we can
basically see that if I have a general
matrix a if I want any non-trivial
approximation down say a minus the
Lorentz approximation is less than
anything less than 1 times a is for
being a storm so anything that I can't
just return zero I better read basically
the whole matrix
so the first observation is this that
this lower bound does not hold for PST
matrices so for PSD matrices we actually
have that for any off diagonal entry
it's bounded by the basically the
maximum of its two on diagonal entries
so that means that if I try to hide the
really big off diagonal entry in the
matrix I'm gonna go an algorithm can
actually find this it can read the
diagonal of the matrix it can look at
all the really large on diagonal entries
and then it can check those columns to
make sure there's not a big off diagonal
hiding so basically if we have a PSD
matrix we can find these heavy off
diagonals we don't have this lower bound
we obviously don't have an algorithm so
the question now becomes what do we
actually do how do we actually get an
algorithm using this sort of intuition
basically how come use additional
structure arising from positive
semi-definite is to actually get like
some non-trivial approximation de in the
additional structure we're going to use
is just a really simple fact which is
just that any positive semi definite
matrix has a square root so basically a
can be written as B transpose B for some
B use whatever your favorite
decomposition is I'm just going to think
of say we have the eigen decomposition
of a B is gonna be basically a square
root of the eigenvalues times b
transpose and know that b is not
something I'm computing algorithmically
B is just sort of a tool I'm gonna use
in my analysis and in my proofs but
every make every PSD matrix has a square
root what does that mean well if I look
at the columns of B then the entries of
a are just the dot products between
these columns basically I J at the entry
of B is the dot product between bi and
BJ and this means that basically a is a
grand matrix whose contains the dot
products between a bunch of
n-dimensional points this puts a lot of
geometric constraints on its entries and
it's sort of these geometric constraints
that we're gonna be able to use to get
faster algorithms for approximating so
this heavy diagonal observation I
mentioned a couple of slides ago be
simulating that ruled out my lower bound
is just a simple corollary of Cowie
Schwarz so basically a IJ is the dot
product between bi and BJ so by Kaui
Schwarz it's bounded by the root
their norms their norms multiplied but
together these norms are just the
diagonal entries of eight so basically
you get AI J is less than the root of
aii times aj j the determinants the
determinant of the principal sub
matrices i know- yep sure
yes price yeah I guess problem yeah you
can also see it that way yeah so yeah
you can see this you you can see this
sort of fact in a number of different
ways but it arises out of this geometric
structure sort of another view that
we're going to take on it and that's
going to help us develop algorithms is
that we're gonna think of a is basically
containing a lot of information about
the com span of B in some very
compressed representation basically we
already have all the dot products
between the columns of B pre computed
for us and we can just access them by
like reading an entry of that order one
cost when typically in order to compute
these com dot products if we're given B
itself we'd have to pay like order n
calls okay so the good news is that if I
want a low-rank approximation of this
factor matrix B we can show how to do
this using less than n squared column
dot products in this corresponds to
using less than N squared accesses to a
and therefore sub linear time algorithm
if I wanted to compute a low-rank
approximation of B explain how to do
this in a second it's not very hard and
we can do it using a lot of methods
developed in this community for
basically like C you are type algorithms
but what does this bias well B as the
sort of saying right singular vectors as
a it's singular values are closely
related they're just the root of the
singular values of a so basically it's
top case singular vectors are related in
finding a low-rank approximation of B is
really closely related to finding a
low-rank approximation so you're not
just showing that be the symmetric
square root no I'm not but we can if you
want you can make it a symmetric square
root two
so for example if I could get an optimal
low-rank approximation for me this would
actually I could immediately use this to
get an optimal low-rank approximation
for a of course in all of these
algorithms that we have there's some
error and things are gonna get
complicated when we reduce error but
this is sort of the intuition we're
gonna focus on getting a low-rank
approximation for this matrix B which we
don't actually have in hand it's just a
proof tool and then we're going to show
that this is we can actually boost this
to a good low rank of oxidation for a
itself oh so how do you do how do you
answer this first question so how do you
actually find a low-rank approximation
of be using less than and square comma
dot products this can be done in a
number of ways it can be done with
leverage score sampling these volume
sampling methods a variety of like CU r
type methods one way to do it that I'll
just use today for exposition because
it's really simple is something called
adaptive sampling so this was a theorem
showed by Deshpande Impala basically
there exists a subset of just K squared
over epsilon columns of any matrix that
spans basically a good Laura proximation
expands some Z such that B minus Z Z
transpose B is within 1 plus epsilon the
best lower entry box
once I found these columns I just in
order to compute this lowering
approximation I just need to know the
dot products with those columns so I
just need to know roughly n times K
squared over epsilon column dot products
and further I can find this low-rank
span this span of a few columns really
efficiently basically I'm going to use a
very simple approach I'm trying to find
columns that span my matrix basically
what I'm going to do is I'm going to
start with you know columns and I'm
going to do it in every step I'm gonna
basically look at for all my remaining
columns project off what I've already
covered project off the comms that I've
already selected and then just select by
the remaining norm select by leonora
move basically column VI minus its
projection off the subspace that I've
already selected so I'm basically keep
trying to collect columns that I haven't
sampled yet that are not covered by my
sub set
in yeah so I sample by these
probabilities this can be implemented
with very few accesses days so how do I
actually implement this algorithm well
in the first step PS is 0 I haven't
added anything to my subset so all I'm
doing is selecting columns by their norm
so what I do is if I want to select the
column of B by its norm the norms of the
columns of B are just written down on
the diagonals of a I read the diagonals
of a and I sample one by its size so in
the first step what I can do is I read
it and obey I get a column that's the
first column in my com subset or reorder
it I'll just apply a permutation and put
at the beginning because it doesn't
matter so note that the first step of
the algorithm reads the diagonal of a
this is sort of critical breaking my
lower bound required reading the entire
diagonal of a so you sort of knew that
was gonna have to come until I have my
algorithm at some point okay in the next
step I need to compute this probability
again well what is this probability I
need so basically for every column I I
need to know one it's norm and I need to
know its component in the direction of
b1 so I just need to know all the dot
products between that in the columns and
b1 these are written down in the first
column of the matrix a so I sample a
second column I reorder it again and
then I keep a Turing like this to
compute the projection off of b1 and b2
I basically need to know all the dot
products with those columns that
requires reading the first two columns
in my matrix a so I can perform this
whole algorithm in the end I read the
diagonal of a which is n entries and
then I read K squared over epsilon
columns so I haven't read the full
matrix so what comes out of this is that
basically there's an algorithm it uses
roughly n K squared accesses to a it's
PSD matrix and it computes some low rank
span that satisfies with good
probability basically if I projected B
on to it this would give me a near
optimal rank of box nation of B and you
can improve this by the way like in the
actual paper we do this we don't use
adaptive sampling technique we use
leverage square specifically ridges
leverage square based techniques this
basically gives you sort of the write
dependence on all the parameters so I
have this algorithm for finding a little
rank span for B what is this good for
well first of all it immediately gives
me at least something for a so how does
this translate to a low-rank
approximation for a if I just convert
these norms from Frobenius want to trace
norm it has the squirts the trace arm is
just a sum of singular values in a
matrix instead of sum of squares
singular values so I exact I I get this
sort of relative error trace norm
approximation bound so already we have
something for getting a low-rank
approximation of a which takes sub
linear time and gives us some sort of
non-trivial down if you don't have
intuition for this trace norm bound this
nice drum algorithm that we give
actually gives a sort of stronger bound
that this trace norm balance a corollary
of which i think is a sort of nice way
of viewing it basically we output a
low-rank approximation and in transpose
that spectrally approximates a it
approximates it to some additive factor
lambda I so basically it gets all the
singular values correct up to somehow
two factor lambda and we essentially get
the optimal treat off between the rank
of n the number of columns in and in
this parameter lambda and this is an
especially useful way of looking at
these algorithms because in like
applications what you often care about
is computing dot products over the
matrix a so for Colonel distance metrics
what I'm doing is exactly computing a
single dot product over this PSD matrix
a for Colonel Ridge regression these
sorts of guarantees are exactly the
right what you want in order to get
approximate solutions so this is another
way to look at what the approximation we
get is and we've done this without
assumptions on a and we've done it
without reading all the entries of a
I'll just mention that this Nystrom
algorithm if you haven't seen it before
is basically like things study in this
community it's like a comm subset
selection method you basically select K
landmark indices which correspond to
rows and columns of your matrix and you
then basically project a a onto these
onto the subset of rows and columns
another way of looking at this algorithm
is that if we think of a as a kernel
matrix as the dot products every entries
the dot products between two things this
basically corresponds to and column
subset selection in kernel space on your
data points so it's actually a very
natural thing to do okay but what about
this what about the Frobenius from
guarantee like I want to actually give
you sort of sub linear time algorithm
that actually achieves this sort of
guarantee I get within 1 plus epsilon of
the best for B Gnaeus or Mehrer of my
matrix how do I actually get this the
first thing to notice is that our nice
drum method and also for example that
adaptive sampling method I described to
you is sort of limited and that actually
only accesses the diagonal of a and some
subset of the columns of a and if we
want to get sort of this stronger
guarantee we're actually gonna have to
do something a little bit more advanced
than this is basically because I can
think of a as being an identity matrix
with this rank one block on it
rank one block of just all ones and this
is a root n by root n block so the
eigenvalues of a are basically all ones
then has an eigenvalue of verb and
basically a constant fraction of a is
for B Gnaeus norm is dominated by this
block so if I want to get a good for
being as norm rank one approximation to
hey I have to mostly find the entries in
this block if I take anything less than
root and columns there's no way that I'm
actually gonna finds most of this block
so I'm not going to get a good
approximation de so this tells me that
column sampling is not gonna give me
anything better than say n to the
three-halves runtime for getting a good
for B Gnaeus normal approximation you
can actually get this sort of runtime
it's still interesting it's still
sublinear you don't need to read the
whole matrix but we want to get
something that's ideally linear' net and
our solution is basically going to be
that we sample both rows and columns and
what we're going to do is sample these
columns and rows I'm not gonna go into
the details at all on this I'm just
going to sort of give you a sketch of
what the algorithm looks like using the
Ridge leverage scores for the factor
matric
the one half or this is what I was
calling me earlier these we can compute
efficiently and what we can show is that
if we sample rows and columns by these
scores I basically you can get down to a
sort of core of my matrix a root m'kay
by root and case some matrix that
contains enough information to actually
identify in your optimal rank
approximation for a the technical tool
we're going to use is something we've
been using a lot in recent work would
you call a projection cost reserving
sketch this is basically I take a I
sample some set of its columns in if I
sample them in the right way for example
by these Ridge leverage scores I get a
matrix that preserves the distance to
any rank K subspace
so I've written that here as basically
for any rank K projection matrix P I
preserve the distance from a a I look at
the distance from a s to pas and this is
within a close approximation factor of
the distance from a to PA what this
means is for example if I compute an
optimal low-rank approximation for a s I
get a near optimal one for a and so I
can use it as basically a stand-in for a
and lorig approximation what we show is
that we get a projection must observe a
sketch first by sampling rows and then
by sampling columns so what our
algorithm looks like is I start with
this PSD matrix a I sample its columns
by these officially computable Ridge
leverage squares of the factor matrix
this gives me a projection coffee
fearing sketch of a I then sample the
rows by the same leverage scores
although it's a different set of rows so
note that this doubly sample matrix it's
not a principal sub matrix it's not a
PSD but it can it is a projection cost
for helix sketch of a s1 and then I can
sort of recover a good lorry
approximation to at first use say an
input sparsity time method to get a good
lor approximation of this sub matrix
note that the sub matrix has at most n
times K entries so if I apply in and put
sparsity time method my run time is
roughly n times K or n times K with some
poly epsilon factors and then using sort
of standard technology I can use this
low-rank approximation along with that
projection cost really sketch guarantees
to find a low-rank span that well
reconstructs a s1 and then in turn find
a low-rank span that while ricans
so the upshot of the whole algorithm is
that we get an algorithm that given a
PSD matrix a axises n K over some factor
epsilon epsilon to the 2.5 entries of
the matrix the runtime is something
similar the runtime is roughly n K
squared over poly epsilon and it outputs
a low rank factorization n times m
transpose that gets within a 1 plus
epsilon of sort of the best and this is
without any assumptions on the matrix a
just using the fact that it's PSD and if
you compare this to for example like a
sort of state-of-the-art runtime for
regular matrices like Clarkson would
dress 2013 your runtime looks like
something in NZ a the time to read the
matrix plus n poly K over epsilon time
basically our runtime looks just like
the second term of this we're basically
totally wiping out the needs this whole
need to read the matrix all right so
yeah you don't in general for longer
back summation you don't need a gap
because I don't care about actually
approximating the singular values or the
vectors I really just care about finding
if there's not a gap then basically the
two singular vectors that are close to
each other singular value wise are just
as good for getting a low-rank
approximation so this is sort of how you
get rid of it one thing to note is that
if my tail if my singular values don't
decay right then in general this norm is
just not going to be that small if my
singular values don't decay this is a
pretty large error so in this sense it
does worse than if you say for example
use like a Crillon of subspace algorithm
okay any other questions a result in
otherwise I'm going to talk about sort
of lower can I quickly talk about future
work okay
so I'll quickly talk about some future
work so there's a lot of open questions
this is sort of a first pass at what can
we do if we start trying to exploit this
PSD structure obviously PSD majors are
super well studied but to us it was
surprising that we could get this sort
of result using pre relatively simple
technique so one question is what can we
what else can we do for PSD matrices we
give some applications in our paper to
approximate Ridge regression are there
other linear algebra problems that
require a second look that we could do a
lot better when we have PSD structure
another question is are there other
natural classes of matrices that emit
sublinear time low-rank approximation so
I saw it like in the upcoming nips that
bakshi and Woodruff have something that
does sub linear time will rank
approximation of distance matrices which
as you can imagine are really closely
related to grand matrices really closer
than a PSD matrices so there's a lot of
other matrices we can maybe be looking
at I'm trying to see can we get these
types of sub linear runtimes
and then the biggest open question that
I'm thinking about and that I think is
sort of an interesting problem is can we
do even better for PSD matrices that
have additional structure like kernel
matrices where we know exactly how this
matrix was generated so say I have an N
by n PSD matrix a it's the kernel matrix
corresponding to some input data X and
some nonlinear kernel function that I
have our methods basically access if I
ignore all the epsilon factors they
access n times K entries of a in order
to compute these entries this requires n
+ Z X times K runtime I need to compute
the kernel distance between roughly K
points but I mean I need to compute
basically the kernel distance between n
K pairs of points and computing this
kernel distance requires reading a row
two rows of the matrix X so the runtime
is something like n n ZX times K David
and I showed that this is sort of the
best you can do so for a huge variety of
kernel functions including the Gaussian
kernel just the standard linear kernel
Paulino
colonels if I want to get any better
approximation any for any proximation of
this form where I have some Delta
relative error to the best rate K
approximation then unless I can
significantly speed up fast rectangular
matrix multiplication I'm not going to
do better than this bounce so we have
sort of a computational lower bound via
reduction to matrix multiplication you
can try to do it but you shouldn't sell
it as a low-rank approximation paper you
would sell it as speeding up matrix
publication but getting n NZXT time is
totally open when we look at this sort
of trace norm approximation result or
how I like to think about is computing a
spectral approximation to this PSD
matrix a in this case we don't know if
we're really basic kernels like the
Gaussian kernel the linear will not the
linear kernel but the Gaussian kernel
the polynomial kernel whether or not we
can get this n NZXT time and I think
that developing tools to try to get this
should lead us to some interesting
results in basically understanding how
to do oblivious embedding for kernel
matrices so let me just say really
quickly what that looks like
kernel matrices one way you can think
about it is I have these data points x1
to xn I apply some mapping that map's
them to really high dimensional space so
it Maps each data point xn to basically
Phi X n which is some high dimensional
vector and then oftentimes by high
dimensional I mean it's an infinite
dimensional vector my kernel matrix a is
just the product it's the grand matrix
of these points in this high dimensional
space it's equal to PI pi transpose so
one thing I could imagine doing to
approximately this kernel matrix is I
could apply random projection this is
what we do all the time here I could
just put this random matrix of say
gaussians in here this would compress
this matrix PI and I get a low-rank
approximation de now of course this
isn't possible to do computationally if
my kernel has for example infinite
dimensions then I can't just multiply it
by an infinite dimensional Gaussian
matrix but it's something that hopefully
we can get some sort of understanding of
what the actual distribution of the
output would be and maybe just directly
compute PI G without actually doing this
kernel expansion so the hope would be
replaced this sort of algorithm that I'm
just using as a sort of template with
basically multiplying
by gee approximating that by multiplying
our original input X before expansion by
a Gaussian and then applying some
nonlinear function and this is actually
exactly what things like the random for
features method which is common machine
learning to they exactly do this type of
thing it's basically a nonlinear random
projection and getting better bounds on
approximating these kernel matrices
basically boils down to getting better
bounds in these nonlinear random
projections so in nips 2017 paper Dave
and I have some initial progress on this
we combine sort of techniques for
faustão seein approximate Gaussian
matrix multiplication with these like
leverage score based fan random for our
features results which I won't talk
about but further progress is definitely
possible
Chris's talk will sort of relate to this
and I think there's a lot of interesting
directions here so yeah that's actually
so in the interest of not each time can
we just eat for questions and let's
thank Cameron Cameron
[Applause]